bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'eux au nord le constructeur chinois
la filiale de huawei honor qui a des
produits super sexy et là on a un tout
nouveau au nord qui a été présenté il
n'y a pas très longtemps
enfin si vous en avez entendu parler
c'est le au nord c'est ta et nous en
tout cas on va en parler maintenant
m
au nord c'est la marque qui monte de
plus en plus avec un honneur view disent
que j'ai testé ya pas très longtemps
la vidéo et la booster et l'intelligence
artificielle une marque qui prend de
plus en plus de place dans les foyers
et là ils nous ont sorti un au nord 7 à
un produit super intéressant qui coûte à
peine plus de 100 euros un produit qui
en tout cas pourrait être vraiment hyper
cool quand on connaît la qualité des
produits au nord alors effectivement
c'est pas un produit qui va être une
bête de compet c'est pas un produit qui
vous permet d'avoir des performances de
dingue c'est pas un produit pour les
gamers
c'est un produit pour des personnes qui
veulent des smartphones exigeant à des
tarifs vraiment raisonnable pour
l'instant je suis très clair ce produit
n'est pas encore commercialisé en france
il a été présenté en chine il sera à mon
avis commercialise en france d'ici très
peu de temps pour l'instant vous avez le
au nord si ça le au nord c'est à devrait
très bientôt arriver donc c'est pour ça
que je prends le temps de vous le
présenter aujourd'hui alors pour faire
un petit peu le tour effectivement comme
je le dis c'est un produit qu'à venir
concurrencer tous les produits entrée de
gamme notamment les samsung la gabegie
les produits de wick aussi qu'ils sont
très très sympa marque française ils
vont venir concurrencer du shiomi
concurrence et voilà plein de produits
d'entrée de gamme est là pour le coup le
au nord c'est à pour être vraiment un
produit super sexy parce qu'en tout cas
d'un point de vue esthétique
il va vraiment tenir cette promesse il a
un design très très proche du au nord
cède ses je sais pas si vous connaissez
ce modèle alors effectivement chez au
nord il ya tellement de modèles entre
les chiffres et les lettres un moment ci
perd 1 console voyait enfin c'est un peu
le bordel mais le 7 a en tout cas est
très proche du 7 c est assez loin du si
ça alors ça y est je vous ai perdu 6 à 7
à 7 c c'est quoi ce bordel je sais mais
moi je me perds mais dites vous bien que
il a un design qui est assez proche d'un
modèle déjà existant chez eux on
retrouve un écran 5,7 pouces 1440 par
720 pixels au format 18 9e et c'est le
format qui s'imposent il continue de
s'imposer qui s'impose en 2007 et
continue de s'imposer en 2010
8 il a un châssis unibody en aluminium
techniquement il tient il est sympa
alors c'est pas non plus le truc le plus
recherché le truc le plus fou le plus
dingue mais en tout cas c'est plutôt
cool
côté processeur et tourner son instinct
dragonne 430 cadencé à 1,4 ghz alors
c'est pas du tout une bête de compétence
est pas le produit vous allez faire
tourner des jeux hyper gourmand et faire
des choses de dingue avec mais pour
avoir un produit qui tient vraiment la
route pourra utiliser des petites
applications pas trop gourmande des
petits jeux mais vraiment pas gourmand
de limeil du coup de téléphone des
réseaux sociaux des choses comme ça ça
fera fondamentalement la faire il a un
double capteur photo à l'arrière 13
mégapixels + 2 mégapixels alors ne
cherchez pas la stabilisation parce que
sur un produit de cette gamme vous n'en
aurez pas chose qui va fonctionner
plutôt pas mal pas de faible luminosité
bon c'est pas faire des souvenirs on va
pas se mentir allez voir vous avez un
capteur 8 mégapixels et vous pouvez
déverrouiller avec le faith in log c'est
à dire la reconnaissance de visage c'est
parce qu'elle plus sécurisé mais pour un
smartphone qui va vous coûter 100 euros
pour un petit peu plus fondamentalement
il ya rien à dire
côté performances ça devrait fonctionner
à peu près lors ça dépend effectivement
de votre consommation parce que on a un
écran comme je vous le disais ah je me
prends les pieds dans les fils ça c'est
ça dans des micro avec des fils un petit
peu comme l hommes de jacques martin
pour les faits plus anciens qu'il ne
regarde à l'école des fans un bateau je
me perds je me perds je me perds donc on
disait une batterie de 3 millions
terreur en écrans de 5,5 pouces format
18/9 ça peut consommer un petit peu mais
ça va vraiment dépendre vous de votre
utilisation donc on va dire qu'on est
une consommation quand même relativement
moyenne il faut savoir que sur l'iphone
disent vous avez une batterie de 2007
180 millions perreur donc bon froid et
soyez pas trop inquiet de toute façon je
pense que leur système est vraiment
optimisé pour que ce ne soit pas trop
gourmand et que ça consomme pas
énormément donc ça devrait faire l
affaire vous allez pouvoir utiliser
sensiblement une journée sont trop trop
vous inquiétez il a un port jack un
lecteur d'empreintes digitales situé au
dos de l'appareil
vous avez la possibilité de mettre une
double carte sim est effectivement une
extension bien noir avec une carte micro
sd
il tourne sous android 8.0 oreo avec une
surcouche maison em
8.0 il est disponible en trois couleurs
le bleu le noir et l'or vous retrouverez
en deux il ya deux rames avec 32 go de
stockage un tarif à peu près de 100
euros hors taxes et 3 giga de ram et 32
go de stockage à peu près à 130 euros
hors taxes alors imagine que c'est ces
produits vont dire un petit peu
remplacer le au nord si ça qui lui est
vendu 169 euros 90 donc c'est des
produits congrès pro aux alentours de
150 160 euros 170 euros
assez facilement mais en attendant avec
un vrai savoir-faire avec une surcouche
maison ou même 8.0 qui est vraiment bien
qui tourne bien avec un produit qui en
tout cas devrait plutôt cool et qui
effectivement en tout cas esthétiquement
fait la sphère donc dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez est ce que c'est un
produit dès lors qu'il arrivera en
france
est ce qu'il pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que vous avez des produits d
honneur parce que je suis au nord les
produits y en a à foison entre le 9 lite
le view 10 le 7x le 6 et le 6 1 le 6 6
le 8 le huit pros le neuf c'est chaud
c'est en fait beaucoup
est-ce que vous avez des produits du
nord mark et moi tout son commentaire
moi ce que vous en pensez et dites-moi
si ce set a pourrait en tout cas
hypothétiquement vous intéresser marc
qui m'a tout ça comme d'habitude vous
invite à vous abonner à blesser des
jolies pouce de tous les côtés parce
qu'on va parler toujours plus toujours
mieux de tech avec plein de produits
avec des produits qui vont arriver des
productrices sont arrivés que ce soit
des smartphones des tablettes de la
robotique des technologies françaises il
ya plein de trucs super cool j'ai plein
de trucs dans les tuyaux donc restez
connectés
comme d'hab vous fait des très gros
mizuno soyez sages prenez soin de vous
et à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]